there we go oh my
assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
better car to brothers and sisters
welcome back to the reality show part 5
as you know a port for it was quite I
want a pious wife so basically on the
reality part for what we did is went out
there in public and went up to certain
men and ask them you know how would you
feel if you found like if you found out
for example your sister has a boyfriend
yeah and obviously before that we asked
them you know do you have a girlfriend
yourself and they were like nah you know
I'm looking to have one you know I have
one so when we asked them to well how
would you react if your sister had a
boyfriend there but now we don't like it
got so bad that actually the reality
part for work the leader of YouTube
because some guys got exposed and always
you should have covered their face but
they didn't tell us just in case you
missed it here's the clip check here if
your wife yeah you're getting married
here and your wife she's she's had
previous relationships she's been with
different guys would you tolerate that
would you would you carry on the
marriage or would you say no I don't
have that
no pinche bro prefer clean sheet well
gonna remove you again yet okay you
should be a virgin yourself first off
use me like alright you got a girlfriend
yet then how does it work when you say
okay let my sister I know it's right I'm
losing myself here I know how it is yeah
isn't that bit almost unders can you
tell us it can you tell us where the
problem arises that's when it becomes
hard that's when it becomes hard that's
how I mean if she starts asking me
questions about it okay what if you do
it then it's hard for me to explain to
her Salaam alaikum so as you know
brother Imran gave a Nasir on that video
because I interviewed him as well and he
was talking about a hadith
you know where Prophet Muhammad upon him
somebody comes up to him and says no you
don't want to say about this hadith they
say that if a man comes to hear about
this and understand this right but if
they violate someone else is sister this
is to make it violated then one of the
ways that a lot punishes them is by
making sure that happens to their sister
by making sure that happens to their
daughter but making sure that happens to
their mom or your auntie and so on and
so now you saw the Nicaea from buddy and
Ronnie been master now I'm gonna stop
them all up you know you saw the
interviews from the last show
you story might be monsters nasiha he
gives and basically what happened now is
what I'm going to explain is basically
Joan Fontaine brother John for attend
you did our to the game the rapid game
rank us up and told us that his video is
out and I'm quite excited and brother
that was quite excited about his role so
basically I will start watching that you
know infuse crew till it came to the
last bit and now look how this all sums
up because on the first interview it
talks about men are seen and I wouldn't
happen to my sister you know but even
though themself have girlfriends yeah
then it might have been muscle tells us
about a hadith of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him how a man comes up and says
make zina permissible for me and he says
would you like that for your sister now
the funny thing with this video is which
is not really fun it's actually really
sad is that the end of the video game
basically comes into a restaurant after
his concert right and it goes in there
and basically what happened is really
really traumatic so basically he's in
there with his crew and then there's a
Muslim guy a Muslim brother of ours and
the couple of sisters which are in one
of them is our sister or friend etc now
he goes up to the game school in hijab
and in hijab and abaya right he goes up
to the game's crew and says he'll fam
you know can I take a picture with some
of your girls you know and then I've
obviously could I don't care you know
those kind of get wasn't girls they use
on a daily basis they don't give up they
don't really care about that so they
said yeah cool fun do you do whatever
you like so listen to what happens now
so as he goes and does that now one of
the games crew goes yo fam he looks over
the thing and is that you Adam goes and
he's like you know he's a uh yeah
they're just my sisters why don't we
swap yeah that back is like a piece of
meat you know it's like some kind of
product you're swapping it was good can
we swap and he's are not dog might not
that's my sister's but obviously the
man's be fingered himself hold on a
second you want to take pieces with our
chicks you know why why can we do
reviewers so anyways look what happens
now so the crew one of the games crew
goes up to the sister yeah I starts
flirting with her yeah you see on the
video how he looks a lack of piece of
meat he lets her up and down I want to
zoom into his face right now look at his
facial expression look at that well
dirty these guys I know this face these
are the kind of guys
dirty nasty kinky abusive manipulative
just filthy stuff we're talking about a
queen how much the movement is a queen
she's a princess America walked or
turned around here man kiss her Ilana
the prophet sallallaahu listen said it
is better for a man to have a new ram
through his head and touch the hand of a
woman that is not halal for her but she
let him kiss his hand yeah Riley stop
saying what happened to you you know
this is this is the funny thing last
week's show we was talking about this
matter and some of you feels my finger
men especially out there would've thing
now a family won't happen there you go
it's a clear-cut ple I just want to
point that out right you would think
that no my sister's good she's a good
girl she's not like that
I'm telling you these assistants with a
job an abaya right and I'm sure they
could go not all day oh good good
because brother John Fontaine told us
that he spoke to the brother and the
sisters would destroy we believe me I
know we believe that hamdulillah but we
need to understand is this when you go
and do such an act and so excuse my
language here so your sisters because
that's how he seems right I'm a small
child will punish you with the creation
you know and that's why he did even
though this is B no one knew it's the
heated moment this what the sister said
to John for did it goes it was in the
heat of the moment you know he just came
and you know basically just grabbed my
hand and kissed it I know the sisters
that would never do that in a million
years never you know what's interesting
is it became a Josie I may Allah have
mercy on him he wrote a book called a
devil do I the disease and the cure
right and in this book he explains in a
beginning that there are rules that a
large panel teller has that are visible
to the eye physical eye if I drop
something on the floor gravity will make
sure it falls if I punch you in the face
oh if they do get him on camera yeah I'm
on camera he's a boxer get my camera
if I do punches you in the face yeah
your face is gonna get bruised there are
physical laws that work in a way but
there are also invisible rules the same
way we know in Opera analysis that no
honey son when he went to his people and
said to the make its stepfather a lock
if you do this this is a law that is
hidden these lumps in but that doesn't
mean it doesn't happen now Allah says in
the Quran that the evil facade
corruption evil has spread for from the
landed as a result of what wrong hands
bring forth so we know whenever you do a
sin there is going to be an immediate
consequence of the sin that is not
physically materially linked but it's
linked in a way that is unvisible
invisible and it may be delayed and that
is the same when you violate someone
else's sister the law in that regard
that is not visible to the eye is that
your sister will be violated that's all
your daughter or your mom or your
nothing like on the reality show which
you watched here may not if you watch
that any for yourself yeah yeah it
happened look there you go that's your
proof if you want to carry on doing it
you do it's gonna happen you know how
was I found look asking my mother is my
witness when you called me from just
forget me just to the web okay
personally speaking I remember I have I
do not remember the last time I saw a
video like this and I had a reaction
like that so when I'm watching this
video I remember not I was not expecting
to see that my hand was that raw and
brother Dawood who runs the Black
History Month project he literally
almost fell off his chair this chair
went all the way back suddenly I get a
phone call from Ali
switch it on the phone brother I'm angry
I'm angry I'm like why are you angry
from his that provide just from this
video I'm hurt man obviously you know
I'm not saying it just that well why
he's here so my surgery in my he's mine
said man said I'm about to cry have to
leave my house because I can't black my
mom's you know oh you might you might
know get any motion no no no you might
you might look here and be that cry over
a video you don't understand you'll
understand the connection with Islam
Islam is not my family you know when I
see a brother in a beard or a cyst on a
hijab
being violated I feel like it's it's
serious like my own
blood it's got my own sister and that's
why you know you might think this a cry
a grown man crying over some video you
don't understand and you don't stand a
connection between us in Islam it really
gets to us man
you know the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasalam said something very interesting
right he said that a person who does not
have freedom a person who basically lets
his sister do whatever she does or less
is whatever she does on the day of
judgment Allah will not even look at
this person's face will not even look at
this person's face
what is the reader readers protective
jealousy it's the kind of like if this
is my wife and you come and touch my
wife and appropriately have to punch you
I have to punch I'm not a man if I don't
want you I'm of course hungry let peace
love everything patience and all that
but if you try to like you try to
violate my woman you try to violate my
sister and she's not done something
wrong me you will have any issue and you
have to have that fun otherwise this
will happen I know this is watching this
video and I know you guys gonna be like
oh those heat yeah because you know the
non each other sisters yeah but looking
at interruption oh yeah
look these each other because all like
that please don't do that you know
because what is we do these videos
people make mistakes
but don't make an excuse that for
example Oh see they're also typing your
zone like that
and that's why you job on the day of
judgment my sister's you know Alice
Walter is not gonna get that excuse you
can't go and say this person did it
you'd be the better person you know you
wear the hijab and don't do these kind
of acts you know I just wanted to clear
this up because obviously know there's
everyone on a routine yeah now let's be
ruin it if a woman wears a hijab she has
like of course no one's perfect people
are gonna sin just because she was hijab
doesn't mean she's not gonna sin doesn't
mean she's not gonna have fit not but in
terms of haha yeah it is one level up of
course it is you can't so you have to
respect that
uniform you run up to me and go please
yummy I'm not looking I'm not police
officer you're expecting when you become
a uniformed
you're expecting some you're like this
guy if I'm being robbed he can help me
exactly but that's no assistance when we
see assists in a buyer automatically
were like we have respectful we look up
to in a way we don't see she's perfect
she's a pious but what we're trying to
say is that she she's carrying something
with her you know and it's the comment
of a law on the flip side if you go and
you see a chick who's not just in her
body I just kind of skimpy yeah and she
can say that she has a hijab in her
heart and a man in her heart
respectfully we know that everyone has
their own struggles where they take
their own steps towards getting higher
inshallah right that go if you go up to
you try chirp sir which I touch her up
and she says you know don't touch me but
it's like you're wearing the uniform of
a chick that wants to be touched up
though you're wearing the uniform of a
chick that I want to thank you
I meant intensity Mirage